cette place au coeur de la vieille ville
de lviv est classé sur la liste du
patrimoine mondial de l'unesco depuis
1998 ses statuts les vitraux de ses
églises ses bâtiments dont certains
datent du xiiie siècle doivent être
protégés ils sont désormais enveloppé de
bâches de mousse de planches de bois en
cas d'une éventuelle attaque un scénario
qui est loin d'être prise à la légère
par la municipalité de lviv
claude et moi je trouve indécent bon
boss rush attaquent les gens peuvent se
réfugier pendant les bombardements alors
que les monuments ne peuvent pas le
faire ces monuments sont dans
l'extérieur et sont en danger nous
devons les protéger les sauvegardes et
pour les générations futures
le cren et le monde entier auront besoin
de ce qui a été protégé ici depuis le
13ème et 14ème siècle il s'agit de notre
mémoire j'ai dédié toute ma vie à
restaurer et à protéger ses monuments et
s'il leur arrive quelque chose ma vie
n'aura plus aucun sens
en l'absence de tout est de la part de
l'unesco pour protéger ce patrimoine les
autorités locales elles vivent demande
au moins que la prochaine session du
comité du patrimoine mondial de l'unesco
très vieux en juin prochain à kazan et
lieu ailleurs qu'en russie